この前友達と
バスの中でゲイ国をしていたら
イギリス人のを者に
苦笑いされたよ
かもよまじでイギリスで警告をやめたほうがいい
全力で惹かれます外国人と仲良くなるためには下ネタが一番いいと思いますよ
simone とあ世界共通ですからもうね何
もうそういうの好きなんすよ外国人コンプ
醤油
なんかね英語を話すんじゃなくて話したいが英語を使うっていうね
なんかそういう
そういう方がなんか英語を学ぶ意欲がわきましたよ
英語マンサポートする人質もネタですよ
下ネタで英語を張れます
スピードラーニングとなくて下ネタラーニングですからねそれがパッケージに惹かれ
ました
なんて呼べばいいんだろうちょっとわかんない
ば ok
ん
バーバせバーセットです
どうなんだろこれ
もうパッケージのこいつに惹かれたからさううッ
いろんな種類のなんかが入ってるっぽいですが
わかんないですねイギリスのお菓子なんだよああ
なんだこれ
あっ組分からない何コード得体が知れない感じ脅威なんですかねこれはつなんなん
だろうね
ギリシャのお菓子は何か日本と何か違うんでしょ
これは組なぁこれだってもいいですなーん
辛口評論家ですよ
俺は
おっ
これはまだいけるって
何とも言えねぇ
4分
a
ん
母
これは厳しいな誰だってみるこのによっちゃ非常にまずいです
なんかほんとにねーうん
じゃん
持っています